i could tell you guys really did not
expect to win at all we had no idea like
why would we like it's just us like why
would we win honestly like i don't think
it's hit us how many people watch us
still this to this day i'm sure you guys
didn't realize that by sharing your
romance and your whole love story on tv
that you'd be walking away with some
hardware we didn't think we would have
been married when we met like we're
married seven years now we never would
have thought this with the third baby
in three years let me hold this for you
thank you it's a little hefty you know
it's in my workout though you're also
used to it like you're used to this
i mean i can take it though oh my god
there he goes listen
get a third one because he's gonna need
some practice i married him because he's
the selfie stick and he's got the height
and i'm very short so you know
what does he need to be named real best
reality romance especially with that
other competition
it's special it's not it's no joke right
then like we didn't think about any of
this but it's big right i am shook
i was like
that's insane thank you to them like
that's thank you to them i think you're
also in disbelief because did you guys
just fly in tonight we literally landed
three hours ago and then you're on a red
eye tonight i heard come on they
literally came in just to collect this
and now they're out
of business
all right so where are these going are
these going in the kids rooms yeah
we give one to the kids right two or one
you guys each get one okay so one in
each room
so you got to come back next year and
win a third one right a third for the
third baby well congratulations y'all so
much absolutely safe travels home too
thank you they're so cute
you